freunde herzlich willkommen zu diesem
neuen video ich bin hier mit tom und ton
ist wirklich ein mann der gutes essen zu
schätzen weiß und vor allem ist kaum
jemand in den letzten monaten muss ich
auch mal sagen sein content richtig
improved hat geile food blogs geile food
tours und so einen genießer die den
lieben lade ich mir auch gerne für eine
folge persönlicher koch ein
und ja was soll ich sagen zum frühstück
gibt es management du hast ja
wahrscheinlich umsonst moment ausgesucht
ich habe dann ist da wohl blog gesehen
so setzt rohrstücke auch mich das und
denken ich kann da mithalten
du hast mich gefragt was ich am liebsten
essen will und ich habe das gesagt ich
soll die herausforderung ja und du weißt
auch alles erst bewerten komplett also
bei mir ist komplett irre und nichts
geschenkt würde das wird hart aber wir
legen los für die management war ich in
einem türkischen supermarkt einkaufen
und habe richtig schön frische zutaten
grütt traditionelle türkische backwaren
und vor allem ganz ganz wichtig grüne
spitz paprika davon habe ich mir dann
auch eine geschnappt oben und unten
abgeschnitten und kerne sowie dieses
weiße innen fleisch rausgeschnitten dann
habe ich die paprikas geplättet in
kleine streifen geschnitten und im
anschluss schön in dünne feine stückchen
nebenbei habe ich schon meine fahne ein
bisschen warm werden lassen hab dann
eine ordentliche menge olivenöl hinein
gegeben und anschließend die spitz
fabbrica das grundrezept von managern
hat neben einer noch eine weitere zutat
und zwar tomaten die habe ich nicht aus
der dose genommen sondern selbst schön
frisch gerieben einfach in einer 4 3
über die grobe seite genommen
dabei funktioniert die haut der tomate
wie ein kleiner schutz für die hand die
spitz paprika so schön weich werden
deshalb müssen wir sie ein bisschen
anbraten da wo ich ein bisschen warten
bis die farbe bekommt ich habe die
management da noch mit youtube erweitert
dafür einfach scheiben aus der wurst
geschnitten
diese noch mal halbiert und mit
angebraten als dann auch die zu jack
angebraten mal habe ich mir die tomaten
geschnappt und sie dazu gegeben die
hatten allerdings noch relativ viel
wasser deshalb musste sie auf jeden fall
ein bisschen köchin das sieht aber auch
schon wirklich sehr sehr schön ausfindig
und jetzt steht nur noch ein letzter
schritt nämlich die eier und anders als
bei kuka pochieren wie die eier nicht in
dieser tomatensoße sondern berühren sie
ein so dass alles eine masse wird dafür
fehlt mir einfach die eigelbe an und
ganz wichtig über mixen das ganze aber
auch nicht sondern gehen paar mal durch
mit dem kochlöffel und so wird das ein
ganz leckere
dazu noch sind und viele frisch anrösten
bei 180 grad im backofen das ganze
nochmal abschmecken mit salz pfeffer
cayenne dann habe ich dazu auch noch
geräucherte paprika gegeben und alles
schön serviert
[Musik]
so leute oder sitzen also komm du sitzt
vor einem frühstück das fürstlich ist
wir haben menschen mit pi de passt immer
frisches gemüse und hier drüben kann
töpfermarkt oder kaymer kaymer ja so in
die richtung ist so ein ding auf jeden
fall mit honig dazu ein frischer
orangensaft lass es dir schmecken oder
ich muss ja schon mal direkt sagen also
sieht wunderschön aus ich bin ja ich bin
ja wirklich auch so ein typ ich liebte
es zum beispiel meine frau zu verwöhnen
ok ich glaube bei dir ist aktuell eine
frau wird sehr sehr gut mit dir weil
sondern optisch immer oder ich finde
sowas immer wunderschön wenn ich sehe
dass die passion dabei ist da freut es
mich für übertrieben darf ich dann noch
mal gerne auf diese typische art und die
ja immer schön dass man hier kurz rein
gucken
okay ist wie gesagt al dente es bei mir
gelernt hat nein ist auf jeden fall
schön flüssig ich gehe ja von auch in
den pausen ich habe auch gelernt weil
meine recherche das man management quasi
eigentlich als clip benutzt also man
nimmt das nur mit brot auch man sollte
das nicht sondern es geht darum mit brot
aufnehmen okay das ist nicht nur
belassen man probiere gern auch ein zwei
flaschen sachen dazu und dann geht ja
wie immer auch die kamera aus und danach
kommt erst die bewertung heißt du kannst
das ganze entspannt auf sich wirken
lassen bin sehr gespannt kammer kennst
du auch diese geschichte macht man
glaube ich also das habe ich sterbe ich
kenne ich das ja also schöner kontrast
zu diesem bisher ja okay leute ich muss
auch ein problem wir sehen uns gleich
wieder
bis gleich das war auf jeden fall eine
ansage und ich habe dieses level an
verrücktheit was essen angeht ist bei
mir schon ziemlich hoch man sagt ich
möchte wenn wenn es das möchte dass jede
zutat perfekt ist aber die ist das
nochmal dieses andere level ich über das
in jedem bissen etwas drin ist dass du
sagst ich möchte das auf dem höchsten
gratis und das ist einfach der wahnsinn
ich sagte ehrlich so ein
hochqualitatives management habe ich
noch nicht gegessen ich habe einen
istanbul glocke
wir sagen das war besser als minister es
ist ein unterschied da ich die gewürze
die in istanbul bahn waren heftiger weiß
aber nicht ob mir das am besten jetzt
gefallen hat weil ich bin immer noch
deutsche
das war leichter damit fand ich sogar
noch verträglicher für mich aber ich
habe auch in der frühe morgen ich habe
noch so einen leichten magen dafür was
für mich perfekt
alles was du dir außenrum gemacht hast
ist einfach erst schön anzusehen
zweitens schmeckt alles geld ist nicht
so dass man eine sache hat wo man sagt
bolliger ist perfekt und das ist für den
versand via du bist verrückt wurst den
jetzt her gekratzt alexander mädchen
supermarkt gold mich was hat er was
heißt das was gibst du ich sagte meinen
95 als ich will dir noch nicht komplett
daran kann ich auf jeden fall arbeiten
ich sage euch so viele leute mittagessen
wird wild wir legen direkt los
beziehungsweise für euch legen wir
direkt los bis dahin schafft am vorabend
habe ich mist ri cha buttermilch und
chicken tenders also hähnchen in filets
geschnappt habe die butter mädchen ein
gefäß gegeben die innen filets
draufgelegt wichtig ist dass die innen
felix wirklich in buttermilch schwimmt
da habe ich mir die zeit genommen habe
ordentlich was rein gekommen das ganze
gut vermengt durch diese kombination
kriegt das chicken wirklich einen super
leckeren geschmack und alles über nacht
in den kühlschrank gestellt
sodann habe ich auch schon die fritteuse
vorgeheizt und wir machen kleinen
beilagensalat da hab ich so wildkräuter
mix genommen unter anderem ist dieser
mann gold drin aber die wahre beilage
ist getrüffeltem kartoffelpüree dafür
müssen wir natürlich erst mal die
kartoffeln schälen schnappen uns nun
schneller und machen das ganze sehr
gründlich wichtig ist dass ihr probiert
mit den schalen die kamera zu treffen
wir schneiden die kartoffeln in
gleichgroße stücke und geben sie in
kaltes wasser das wasser salz mir dann
großzügig und lassen die kartoffeln
kochen weiter geht es mit unserem
hähnchen den man jetzt die panade die
besteht aus mehl paprika oregano und
verfahrens als alles gut vermischen
damit es gleichmäßig verteilt ist in der
zwischenzeit sind auch unsere kartoffeln
fertig geworden die schütten wir ab und
ich weiss ich sage das immer guter stich
butter aber ihr seht selbst was das für
ein ossi ist trüffelöl dran ein bisschen
milch bisschen muskat und dann stampft
mir das ganze allerdings nicht zu fein
das chicken wandert jetzt aus der
marinade in die parade
wir werfen das ganze ein bisschen durch
und wenn es von allen seiten bedeckt ist
können es auch schon in den korb zum
frittieren geben und wenn der voll ist
frittieren noch eine schnelle wenig red
für den salat olivenöl balsamico honig
die chance im frischer pfeffer etwas und
das ganze schön im regieren ihr seht wie
dickflüssig das geworden ist salat zum
dressing und anrichten was gerade noch
gesagt oft kemna dass das dein
lieblingsessen ist ne das ist turia ich
liebe schicken tennis und vor allem die
trainiert aber wir haben über nacht in
buttermilch creature marinierte chicken
tenders die haben eine super mario
getrüffeltem kartoffelpüree mit triple
chips obendrauf noch und dazu einfach so
kahl ibm mäßig so ein kleiner salat so
dass man auch ein bisschen was grün ist
drin hat dass die schmecken und ehrlich
ist für dich tun mir die kleider fun
fact bevor tom und ich kennen uns
übrigens aus der schule wir waren in der
parallelklasse und irgendwann hatten so
geschrieben so ja hab mir sehen das auf
youtube videos
es war schon echt lustig weil ich dir
ganz ganz am anfang so geschrieben und
da war ich noch ganz ganz kleiner fuchs
hatte ich irgendwie 10.000 ihn gefragt
was ich verbessern kann mein video und
ich habe glaube ich natürlich hier und
ich hab eigentlich gutes feedback
bekommen und jetzt ungefähr ein jahr
später oder was ja jetzt mal hier und
das ist echt lustig war ja schon eine
wilde zeit schulz aschaffenburg
connection mittlerweile riefen ihr merkt
schon gutes pflaster aber kombinieren
sagt der schmeckt ich musste aber mit
dem mit nochmal die ja ich wollte gerade
sagen
orange ist auch dann wenn man härter
sein wissen was in deutschland bewerten
du kannst gerne dann erstmal druck zu
teilen mutter bremst schicken das hat
der tipp mit dem über nacht worden doch
er ich habe gestern überlegt ob es nicht
noch heute morgen mache aber über nacht
einfach wichtig aber die komplette
bewirtung soll ich euch gleich das dass
schmidt das mögen teller leer gefegt
komm ich hoffe es hat ihm geschmeckt
immer noch so aufgegessen ist und ich
gebe ein bisschen kritikern die sache
unbedingt nebra ist hier auf jeden fall
sagen muss dass schicken bezahlt also
wirklich super die sie über nacht
geschichte hat es echt nur ausgesetzt
das sind die sachen sie macht ihr die
man hat ist diese liebe so van der sars
will das thema aber ich muss sagen hast
du das einmal paniert oder zweimal
einmal ich bin nämlich der typ davon
dass diese kruste noch mal heftiger ist
das heißt ich würde ich einmal rein tun
und dann auch immer zweimal parieren
aber was am wichtigsten ist dass es
kicken zartes und das war es auf jeden
fall fertig entwickelte kartoffeln die
war ein bisschen kalt ok muss dir sagen
liegt vielleicht daran dass wir den
ganzen vorstand dieses gemacht haben ja
aber muss man dazu sagen dadurch ein
bisschen der genuss weggegangen trüffel
note super aber die könnte noch
intensiver seiner okay es war
wahrscheinlich habe ich auch gesehen
dass öl rangemacht ja wenn doch mal ein
drittel aber das ist eine andere
geschichte
ein frischer tripwire na ja es hat
schwer zu bekommen ich war nicht ich
hätte ich hätte einen besorgen können
ich habe einen trüffel robl da aber die
chips sahen gut aus haben für mich jetzt
nicht so wirklich sind gelten salat
der salat an sich die die salatblätter
war ein bisschen bitter aber das wenig
redmann 10 also dass wenn ihr gerät war
super abgeschmeckt mit honig drin
das was an säure drin war wurde durch so
ausgeglichen dass der salat an sich war
mir so ein bisschen zu bitten
mangold rundes ding mein resümee 815
weil die chicken sehr gut war geil der
chicken das setzt hat und das fühle ich
das ist das wichtigste eigentlich ja ich
hätte auf den restaurant kritiker müssen
und den teller voller wäre das aber dem
kartoffelpüree geklappt aber ein
bisschen
und jetzt ist die motivation fürs
abendessen auch wieder da wir sehen uns
gleich vier zutaten käse steak zwiebel
brot idealerweise der mittelteil von
einem baguette wir schneiden unser
fleisch das ist ein rekord in feine
streifen ist hilft wenn man das ganze
friert ich habe es aber nicht lang genug
drin gelassen
ach ja falls es bisher noch nicht klar
ist wir machen ein philippi steak
sandwich dazu schneiden wir das deck
dann nochmal in kleine stücke dann
starten wir uns eine zwiebel werfen sie
hoch und halbieren sie die würfeln wir
dann noch grob neben unserer baguette
und nein okay
diesmal nicht genehm ist und halbieren
ist eben nicht man lässt das ganze unten
zusammen ich habe es verkackt und hab
dann ein anderes stück genommen alle
zutaten bis auf der käse sind abgehakt
ich habe das gar mords wahrgenommen
einfach weil es noch mal schön rauchigen
geschmack rhein gibt in dünne dünne
scheiben geschnitten und wir konnten
rüber zum grill auf der gusseisernen
platten schön heißt das steak angebraten
nebenan noch die zwiebeln fertig gemacht
mit einem stich butter
dann haben wir das ding natürlich
gewürzt den sck am ortsrand drauf
gegeben und dann habe ich das mit einer
form abgedeckt damit der käse noch
schöner schmilzt dann kommt er wichtige
move wie heben mit dem baguette die
gesamte füllung einfach auf und fertig
ist das filet steak sandwich
[Musik]
die letzte mahlzeit des tages wirklich
einfach simpel aber sexy du hast gesagt
uns noch nicht gegessen ich habe es noch
nicht gegessen
du weißt dass aber wahrscheinlich schon
probieren ja ich wollte auf jeden fall
mal selbst ausprobieren auch ja ich habe
schon gesehen so käser darauf ist
programm ort sei dann auch schön
geräucherter käse der schön sie ist heiß
ist das ganze noch lohnt der dampf der
noch bleibt nichts anderes übrig als
einmal rein zu snacken
es ist quasi ummantelt von käse schön
geräte zwiebel und weiches bett ich habe
das extra eingewickelt in eine tüte
damit es besser wird
mal ganz kurz elf wird der käse wo sich
zieht alter das wild leute ich gucke
jetzt auch und wir sehen uns gleich zur
bewertung wieder let's go also das war
auf jeden fall ein würdiges abendessen
eine würdige dritte mahlzeit und ich
stehe zwar noch einen teller ich habe
aber auch gerade gegessen und ich sage
euch es macht dann auf jeden fall fährt
wie sieht dieses essen oder ich bin
schon platt jetzt aber hat sie ist
gelungen
das nehme auf jeden fall ich sag dir mal
ehrlich dieser käse passt sehr gut dar
ein mann absolute ich möchte hier noch
welchen absolute ergänzung zu diesem
kräftigen fleisch das aber es war gute
tat.de sagt der sich in diesem brötchen
wieder gefunden hat war der band sind ja
nie wirklich ich fühle ich fühle was
meinst du auch wenn ich selbst gemacht
habe aber ich kann auch was uns sehr gut
ja ja die zwiebel haben das gerne süßes
mit reihen gegeben was ich dachte dass
die zwiebeln zu unangebrachten sind aber
das war genau richtig schön glasigen
augen zufrieden mit meiner leistung
jetzt bin ich gespannt wie du sie
bewährt ist ich überlegte was ich aus
setzen kannst du bist doch eigentlich
den kritischen rechnern übrigens ja er
hat auch sehr selbstkritisch ich bei mir
bin ich auch immer sehr sehr hart ja ja
ich kann dich kannst du über die lippen
kommt mein freund aber wurde das ist
schon super es ist es ist schon zehnte
214 ja ich darf hier nicht bei dem
frühstück da ist mir bei heute morgen
der ich habe es krank gefühlt was man
kaufen ich dachte nur gemüse richtig
harte nuss
jetzt fangen wir freuen uns sagen was es
für saniert vier zutaten die man alle
perfekt miteinander gemischt es hat
alles gepasst
vielleicht war zwiebel perfekt dieser
käse rundes ding was euch die songs ist
muss halt auch fair sein
das hört man gerne leute endlich mal
wieder eine folge persönlicher kochen
dann auch noch so eine schöne kombis
kanadier fürs dabeisein genau 42 sehr
wild ich habe gar nicht gesagt am anfang
des videos aber wir haben auch für tom
ein video aufgenommen
dann will die geheimsten foods in köln
getestet gleich fünf stück lohnt sich
also auf jeden fall reinzuschauen
verlinkt danke fürs zu sehen bastian
like da bis zum nächsten match